we're faithful to death I would die for
you right I remember getting a call from
the guy that I left in charge of
everything when I finally retired they
were going house-to-house looking for
him to kill him I was a blocks away from
in my house two o'clock in the morning
and literally it was so bad that people
were knocking on the house to see where
he hit he called me I didn't have time
to call a bunch of people I got on my
car and I drove in the sidewalk I got
shot 28 times where my car looked like a
strainer and I didn't even get a scratch
but I would die for him right because I
felt that like I told everyone no word
for me no one gets killed for telling
the truth but what happens is that the
Academy is we're super loyal to each
other but you just can't have one woman
you're not a real man you gotta have two
three mistresses mm-hmm so in my
faithful or am I not faithful I can't be
say I'm a man here I'm faithful here and
I was cheat here the others cheat or
you're faithful right and that's how all
of life is and for me that emptiness I
mean you and I having so much money I
run one time so I had a sofa that was
scary cool imagine that so far there
catty-corner and I'm sitting there in
that sofa and in that corner my
housekeeper come and says I haven't
swept behind there you know in a couple
weeks
seeing you here in your office but you
mind moving the sofa suck in sleep I'm
sure I move the sofa and there's a bag
with $700,000 I didn't even know who the
hell dropped it there I didn't even know
how long it'd been there or what it was
doing there that's how much freaking
money we had you know we're doing 50
million dollars a month in 77 you know
and so money's not what motivates you
now power is very addictive when people
say do you miss your life [ __ ]
especially when I fight coach of course
I miss my life but I don't miss the
consequences on my life the emptiness of
my life or were traded for how I felt
and how I feel now
and the meaning I have and the purpose I
have for my life and what I know what I
was created for but power is what I do
every day still miss and that's why you
see multi-billionaire sell everything to
become a politician right because that
power is so addictive man that power
that especially when I came out out of
the world and someone would do something
to me and I would sit back and say you
know that son of a [ __ ] if he thought
about doing that forget about doing it
thought about it he would hung himself
and now they do it like so she's a
Christian you never do nothing you know
and you know I needed anything I
remember going to concerts and sitting
like right there in the front without
even paying for the tent on those seats
you know you live that and you can give
whatever you want and you can buy
whatever so very very addictive but it's
so empty and and what happens it eats
you up inside
mm-hmm you know and my life had meaning
that they I walked after forfeit all
those millions and I walked into that
cell in Mobile Alabama and I remember
another inmate saying Milky Way Milky
Way milk around Lane
what's Milky Way and this guy said I
said dude what's the big deal about a
Milky Way he's like he's like oh they
only get him every two weeks I say how
much I dot I had not had a meal in two
days because I was arrested in
Springfield every time they moved me
from one place to the other was doing
real time so I missed all those meal I
was dying for the Milky Way and I sat
there in that steel bet and I said to
myself damn two hours ago I was a
multi-millionaire and I freakin down to
buy Milky Way unbelievable and then but
I felt that for the first time in my
life my life had meaning I was created
for something much greater than what I
had sold out to and I had taken the
shortcut I had taken the easy road not
the easy but the fast road because
people say oh you know you were a
millionaire because you were drug dealer
say yeah I was in prison with 3,000 dead
broke drug dealers I was the only one
have all our money
mm-hmm so no you're not miracle yeah I
fast money but it's not easy money and
every other dude wants to kill you
every one fourth in the world was to put
you in jail everything against you is
against all odds mm-hmm so there's
nothing easy about any of it I mean
literally we were five minutes off mark
on any smuggling run if we could lose
the load and people go to jail or die so
I mean everything I was like clockwork
so you know and and then when I realized
that you know yeah I might not have
money but you know I'm not empty no more
I believe that I was created for a
greater purpose and and God would reveal
that purpose to me eventually and I can
take this horrific life I lived in this
horrific choices and the consequences I
paid because I was as reasoning do you
do what you do to pay for the wrong you
did I said no there's nothing I can do
to pay for the wrong I did I know the
wrong I did I should deserve to die in
prison but the truth of the matter is
that God had mercy but I paid in
unbelievable ways I do what I do because
I feel that that's my mission to make a
difference in the world because I
believe one person in God is a majority
and if you look at every great movement
in life hasn't been done by a lot of
people Mother Teresa
changed the world it was just a simple
nut in Calcutta Gandhi you know all
those people those people have felt that
they could do something they didn't need
a bunch of people and look I said if at
the end of the day if I just changed
that one kid that write me a letter the
other day from prison I've been in
prison for six years he's 19 years old
and he's like I'm gonna give it a shot
now you know I'm gonna change my life
just go he'd read that this little
simple book yeah you know yeah and and
you know we've sent fourteen thousand of
those books this year as a June night
now to prisons all over America my
mission to send a million my mission is
to call attention to this war on drugs
and to tell people rise up don't burn
the cities burn government hot with a
torch for with your vote right you know
elect people that will care about the
communities and you that we that have
made it we people of color that how many
you Michael Jordan you Collier vine you
all you guys that are now giving
millions well you know what it's never
too late but let's go and change our
community let's do like LeBron
and changed the a current of a currents
of the world and changed all those
cities and you watch how those kids that
were destined to be imprisoned for the
rest of their life and died and your
dollar and my C because this is a funny
thing about this drug ward all this
[ __ ] yeah prison incarceration yeah
I mean what what are we 14 percent of
the prison's population we have 26
percent of all the prisoners of the
world
what are we guess what oh it's got my my
[ __ ] is your text all in mine so we
can give the government money for this
[ __ ] and we cannot American cannot
have health care right can have the kids
are graduating with a mortgage without
owning a home you know so that's how
that's how we burn things we got a boat
because the other day look and at the
same time not all politicians are
corrupt not all politicians or evil this
great man and great women that feel our
calling to serve but a lot of them are a
lot of them are crooks yeah you know and
and they're there
let's have term limits man you get to
serve one time get the hell out Federal
Elections they gonna pay for everybody's
election everybody gets the same amount
of money so so that the guy that can
raise a building cannot beat the guy
that can only raise down a thousand so
that then people can run for office and
not be indebted to the war machine why
are we spending so much money in nuclear
weapons when we realized no one's going
to drop a nuclear bomb but looking a
little virus man shut down the whole
world mm-hmm
think about that so we got to wake up
and when we make it we can't abandon
those left behind see look at what
Cubans did in Miami we were a minority
here we were we were as discriminating
as anybody ever was we didn't burn the
city down
we got reunited reunited yeah and my dad
made me go to the same dentist that was
our dentist in Cuba even though oh he
had it's a frickin drill that his wife
was out there with the pedal peddling to
get that thing running no novocaine he
put a block of ice and that was
anesthesia but that was a dental and
look at the money in our community and
well look what Miami is now it's hard to
consider it I mean it's hard to think
about uniting when all the politicians
are are incentivized to divide everybody
and media today look at media right it's
crazy yeah you know just for the hell of
it I'll turn on CNN for ten minutes and
I'll turn on Fox for ten minutes they're
talking about opposite extremes of the
world now somewhere in the middle lies
the truth or whatever they're saying
mm-hmm
you know and it's crazy mm-hmm have to
come have the country loves somebody and
the other half hates somebody and I
thought that this virus was going to
unite us as a nation because we realized
or our lives were intertwined knowledge
exactly exactly exactly no matter what
the president look I didn't vote for the
president any vote for the other one but
I want to tell you something here my
president and I and I don't like things
that he does for many reasons all right
but his success is mine why the hell
don't want him to fail I didn't vote for
Obama either as a matter fact honestly
to be transparent I bet this friend of
mine $5,000 twice that America would not
elect a black man really so I was happy
when he got elected I've been a republic
on my life right because but not the
Republicans on our I'm a social
conservative in small government I
believe in Family Values you know I
believe in life but at the same time I
believe in all life so when my Catholic
brother Mac as a fight for pro-life and
anti abortion my question is why we're
not fighting for that poor immigrant
child in the borders in a cage we only
want to fight for the one not born
why don't we fight for the woman that
find alternative but to get an abortion
no woman wants to get an abortion you
know but when you're barely making it or
whatever circumstance in life are why do
we have to go to Russia and China to
adopt a child when women here you know
we can't adopt one in the US
[Laughter]